teachers are the single most important
actor in students learning hi I'm Sal
Khan founder of the not-for-profit
organisation Khan Academy and I just
want to tell all you teachers out there
that we have an exciting program for
this summer
it's called Khan Academy teacher
training and we want to do everything
that we can to ensure that you have the
content the software the tools and the
training to best meet the needs of your
students and so Khan Academy teacher
training is a learning program that will
take you about an hour that allow you to
learn from other teachers who are
successfully using Khan Academy and
seeing gains in their classroom you'll
get guides on how to use it in your
classroom and we'll also encourage you
to have a plan for how you might want to
implement it if you complete this
roughly one hour you'll get a
certificate and a chance to come visit
us so that we can learn more from each
other so I encourage you to participate
this summer I think together we can
really make a big difference for
learners everywhere